yo mark meredith joins us live now look
at how the staffers are dealing with the
news of the outbreak and
what are you hearing from there today
mark bill good afternoon as you can
imagine the white house has really tried
to adapt to what's been going on here
in the last 48 hours or so what we have
learned is that the vice president and
mrs pence
she they both tested negative for
coronavirus they get tested daily and
there's been a lot of talk about who the
vice president
would or would not have come into
contact with of course the vice
president
very busy himself he is scheduled to
hold a conference call
with the coronavirus task force later
this afternoon that's going to be
happening at the naval observatory
that's the
vice president's residence just a few
miles up the road next week the vice
president is still scheduled to go to
salt lake city for his debate one-on-one
with california senator kamala harris we
also have learned that the vice
president is going to be stepping up on
the campaign trail he's going to be
holding an event in arizona on thursday
as you know president trump has
postponed his in-person campaign events
for the time being the president was
supposed to be in wisconsin today
meantime first lady melania trump she
remains here at the white house we got
an update on her condition from the
doctors
during that news conference after she
tested positive along with the president
we also heard from her spokesperson
earlier today they say quote
mrs trump is doing well her symptoms
have not worsened and she continues to
rest
she remains in touch with her husband
she is thinking of all who are ill
and wishes them a speedy recovery now of
course we've been trying to work
backwards here figuring out exactly who
has tested positive who hasn't
we also in addition to the president
first lady we know that the advisor hope
hicks
as well as campaign manager bill stephen
and former counselor kellyanne conway
she's no longer a white house staffer
but she was spotted at the supreme court
nomination a week ago the one that was
saturday at the rose garden
she tweeted out overnight tonight i
tested positive for coven 19.
my symptoms are mild like cough and i'm
feeling fine i have begun a quarantine
process
in consultation with physicians as
always my heart is with everyone
affected by this global pandemic
kellyanne conway who again
is no longer a white house staffer but
she was spotted here just a week ago
we also have learned that governor
former new jersey governor chris
christie has tested positive
he was here at the white house last week
when the president held a news
conference on sunday night
that was as they were getting ready for
the debate that first debate with joe
biden
chris christie was in the briefing room
seated right next to rudy giuliani as
well as white house press secretary
kelly mcinenneny
governor christie says he is going to be
going to speak with his medical
officials
a little bit later on today and then
we'll update the appropriate people
as we've been here at the white house i
haven't seen anything different bill
from coming into work today
you go through a secret service
checkpoint people have their masks on
but they're not doing temperature checks
it is a saturday so there are fewer
staffers around and we in the white
house press corps we have our masks on
when we're
going inside the white house press
briefing room other than that it really
does seem to be business as usual around
here
bill okay mark thank you gonna come back
to you next hour we'll get
a sense of whether or not there's any
change in protocol there mark thank you